Traduttore: Arianna Chittani
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buonasera a tutte e a tutti.
Sono molto lieto
di essere qui a Trento,
una città che mi è molto cara
dove ho vissuto per 8 anni,
e che ho lasciato cinque anni fa.
Ho lasciato la carriera accademica,
ero ricercatore
presso la facoltà di ingegneria a Povo,
per seguire un altro tipo
di accademia attraverso l'unione,
raggiungendo lo studio
con il centro studi Bakhtivedanta
che si occupa
delle scienze tradizionali dell'India.
Quindi c'è sempre
la componente accademica,
ma legata alla componente spirituale.
La mia scelta è stata dettata
non tanto perché non fossi felice
dal punto di vista professionale e umano,
anzi, ero molto felice
da quel punto di vista,
ma proprio perché sentivo
l'esigenza di fare un percorso interiore.
Nel 2002 ho sentito
dentro di me forte questa esigenza.
La troppa razionalità
e il troppo positivismo
mi opprimeva
e non mi faceva sentire felice.
Finché nel 2007 ho fatto questo salto.
Ricordo che all'epoca
la mia scelta creò qualche riflessione.
Giravano anche delle notizie
abbastanza strane.
Ad esempio, una volta ero sull'autobus
che dalla stazione porta fino a Povo
e uno studente venne da me e mi disse:
"Oh prof, girano delle voci strane
su di lei, pare che va in Tibet".
E io gli ho detto:
"No vado semplicemente in Toscana,
vado presso il centro studi Baktivedanta
e lì mi occupo
di scienze tradizionali dell'India."
Vorrei condividere allora con voi
questa riflessione importante
sull'etica e sulla morale
perché è fondamentale
questo tipo di riflessione oggi,
in questo mondo che sta correndo
così vertiginosamente,
ma non seguendo
quei valori essenziali e profondi
che appartengono alla vita di ogni essere.
La Bhagavad-gita è un testo sapienziale
importantissimo
nella tradizione indovedica
indica che tutto ciò
che compie un grande uomo
e per grande uomo intende
un uomo fondato eticamente,
allora tutto il mondo segue le sue orme.
Un po' quello che diceva anche Gandhi
quando diceva:
"Sii il cambiamento
che vorresti vedere nel mondo!"
Indicando proprio una responsabilità
individuale nel cambiamento.
Quindi se vogliamo cambiare
e portare un cambiamento reale
dobbiamo essere noi
a farci portatori di questo cambiamento.
Purtroppo questo
vale anche in senso negativo, ahimè!
Perché se molte cose brutte
sono accadute nel secolo scorso,
sono accadute in virtù
della presenza di personalità ottenebrate,
ma anche perché molte persone
le hanno supportate
nella loro visione distorta.
Ed è per questo che è fondamentale
la responsabilità individuale
nel creare un obiettivo supremo,
un obiettivo trascendente.
Il Baghavata Purana
che è un'altra scrittura molto importante
all'interno della tradizione
del bakhti-yoga,
individua questo obiettivo
e dice chiaramente in toni forti,
perché utilizza toni forti
proprio per scuotere le coscienze,
che qualsiasi occupazione
sul piano mondano e materiale
ha uno scopo inutile se non suscita
un'attrazione per la visione trascendente.
Quella visione trascendente è essenziale
a raggiungere interiormente l'ispirazione.
Quell'ispirazione
che porta alla creatività vera.
Ed è dalla creatività che arriva
poi l'innovazione e quindi la crescita,
ma una crescita motivata,
fondata su valori etici, reali e assoluti,
quindi per questo sostenibili
e portatori di reale benessere.
Quindi il quesito che ci possiamo porre è:
esiste in noi una potenzialità che tende
ad aiutarci a evolvere per il nostro bene?
Cosa determina la nostra potenzialità
ad agire in un senso evolutivo?
E quali sono i fattori
che sviluppano questa potenzialità?
Quali invece la rendono inibita?
E quali sono i mezzi
per raggiungere questa potenzialità
e per potervi quindi anche rimanere
a quel livello potenziale innato
e ontologico
che è presente dentro di noi?
Purtroppo oggi la disposizione delle cose
non aiuta in questo senso.
[Ateismo, Barbarismo e degrado Sociale]
Il separare dalla nostra vita
a livello interiore e personale
ciò che è spirituale
da ciò che è materiale
e quindi suddividendo
le materie e le aree di studio,
si è creata una frammentazione profonda
che non esisteva a livello storico.
Se andiamo a vedere i grandi filosofi
avevano una visione unificata delle arti.
Si parlava di filosofia, di spiritualità,
e di matematica
ma sempre con una centralità.
All'interno della tradizione vedica
della tradizione dello yoga è così.
C'è sempre una centralità
attorno alla quale ruotano le discipline.
Questo ha portato a una frammentazione.
Questo ha portato ad una scissione
nella quale si è perso l'orizzonte
di senso individuale e personale.
Si è andati verso una visione
più orientata alla superficialità
e meno orientata
ad una visione di senso profondo,
ad una ricerca interiore
di quell'aspetto di ispirazione
che ci appartiene ontologicamente.
Viviamo infatti per questo
in una società fortemente relativista,
in cui valgono sistemi di riferimento
relativi e non assoluti.
Una società conflittuogena:
oggi la conflittualità è molto diffusa.
[Società relativista
conflittuogena, frammentante]
É un dato purtroppo ben noto
il fatto che la metà dei matrimoni
finiscono in divorzio,
e il 40% dei bambini
nasce al di fuori del matrimonio.
Si tratta di una conflittualità
molto diffusa anche a livello lavorativo.
Quindi relazioni che non sono armonizzate.
Ho letto un sondaggio che diceva che
i giovani tra i 18 e i 35 anni
mediamente hanno 237 amici su Facebook.
Quando si è chiesto
su quali di questi amici
veramente si può contare
in caso di crisi personale,
la media ha risposto due,
un quarto uno e un ottavo nessuno.
Questo è veramente
qualcosa di interessante
che ci indica qual'è
il livello sociale che stiamo vivendo.
Certamente i mezzi di informazione
non ci aiutano in questo senso.
[Mezzi di dis-informazione]
Spesso infatti le notizie
vengono opportunamente divulgate
per indicare e deviare
una certa modalità di percezione
e un certo modello di pensiero,
che non facilita l'individuazione
di un'opinione personale.
Questo aumenta e facilita
il fenomeno dell'influenzamento,
ovvero quello di creare dei
condizionamenti e false identificazioni
che ci allontanano sempre più
dalla ricerca di chi veramente siamo.
Una volta ho letto
su un tabellone pubblicitario
"X crea il tuo stile".
Però, se X crea il mio stile
allora non è più il mio stile.
Quello è lo stile di X.
Quindi l'importanza di individuare
una propria centratura personale
e capire chi veramente siamo
e orientarci proprio a quello
per individuare una nostra dimensione
vera, assoluta e profonda.
Questo perché l'essere umano
è sostanzialmente un paradosso,
ovvero è suddiviso tra due proporzioni:
una componente armonica,
sintropica, empatica
e una componente entropica.
La componente entropica
porta a disordine,
quella che porta
ad una trasformazione continua,
quella più legata alla materia
e la possiamo vedere come l'ego.
La componente sintropica
la possiamo vedere come il sé,
la componente più profonda
della personalità umana.
Anche nelle relazioni di questa mattina,
che ho apprezzato molto,
ho cercato
di individuare un filo conduttore.
Il filo conduttore che ho trovato
è proprio la componente empatica.
Quella che unisce
le relazioni e le persone.
Quella che consente di creare
qualcosa di vero, sostenibile e creativo.
Ed è proprio questa componente
che dovremmo conoscere profondamente
realizzarla e portarla poi a compimento,
cercando di utilizzare
la componente entropica,
quella della continua trasformazione
come strumentale
alla nostra realizzazione profonda.
Quindi non un qualcosa da negare,
non un qualcosa da allontanarci
perché lo yoga non stimola ad una fuga,
ma anzi stimola ad un agire nel mondo,
ma un agire nel mondo distaccato,
quindi collegato ad un piano superiore,
trascendente, vero, reale, attuale
e sostenibile
legato alla profondità dell'essere.
Questa visione così conflittuale
tra la componente entropica e sintropica
presente in ogni personalità
è quella che porta ad una scissione
Quindi le persone
non sentendosi contestualizzate,
non vedono e non percependo
una dimensione di un orizzonte di senso,
quello che accade è che appunto
sentono dentro profondamente
una visione sciista
che le porta in ultima analisi
ad una conflittualità intrapersonale
e ad una conflittualità interpersonale,
che è la causa dei problemi sociali
che noi troviamo.
Ma è possibile recuperare
questa dimensione,
perché l'essere umano
ha una tendenza innata
all'ordine, alla compassione
e all'empatia,
perché è la sua dimensione vera
è la sua dimensione profonda,
ed è proprio questa dimensione profonda
che bisogna ricercare
attraverso un atto volitivo
per cambiare dalla biologia
delle credenze
delle false identificazioni,
dei condizionamenti,
verso una teologia delle emozioni.
Perché teologia delle emozioni?
Perché le emozioni
non sono un qualcosa da negare
non sono un qualcosa
da cui allontanarci
ma sono un qualcosa da armonizzare,
e da conoscere profondamente.
Io, attraverso il centro studi
Bakhtivedanta
svolgo diversi seminari
nell'ambito del counseling,
quindi ho l'opportunità
di seguire le persone e conoscerle.
Vedo che la maggior parte delle persone
non riesce veramente a sentirsi.
Cioè quando si chiede
"che emozione stai provando?"
difficilmente le persone
riescono a rispondere.
"Qual è il tuo sentire in questo momento?"
difficilmente le persone
riescono a contestualizzarsi.
Quindi è importante recuperare
questa dimensione del sentire
in cui impariamo a conoscerci
e a trasformare le emozioni.
Trasformarle in un senso positivo,
evolutivo e progettuale,
alla ricerca proprio di quella
ispirazione interiore e personale.
Proprio perché così
è possibile integrare la personalità
e superare l'origine del conflitto
che è un conflitto interiore
di non conoscenza di se stessi.
Il metodo richiede
naturalmente una disciplina,
una disciplina personale
che parte innanzitutto dalla conoscenza,
dalla conoscenza di chi siamo
e passa attraverso l'esperienza,
quindi l'esperienza pratica nel mondo
di quella conoscenza.
Perché attraverso l'esperienza
è possibile poi provare l'emozione.
Quindi provare quello che è chiamato
un gusto superiore,
un gusto che consente di andare oltre
i vincoli del condizionamento,
i vincoli dell'identificazione
ed i vincoli della non percezione di sé,
e radicandosi con quell'emozione sana,
vera, ontologica,
è possibile acquisire quella saggezza,
quindi una comprensione profonda
di quella conoscenza,
ed una saggezza interiore, personale
che consente di fare lo step evolutivo.
Dallo step evolutivo,
è possibile acquisire nuove conoscenze,
quindi entrare in un circuito virtuoso
che porta verso l'evoluzione.
La psicologia dello yoga
individua sostanzialmente tre aspetti.
Il primo aspetto è chiamato Sambandha
ovvero la conoscenza della relazione,
quindi la conoscenza
della relazione ontologica
che sussiste tra noi
e una dimensione transcendente
che è quella che dà un senso
alla nostra vita,
quella che dà un senso
alle nostre relazioni oggi
a livello famigliare, amicale, lavorativo,
quindi è la conoscenza ontologica,
perché tutta la conoscenza
della relazione è ontologica
perché tutte le relazioni sono
una dimensione della relazione originaria,
e attraverso i mezzi
per acquisire questa relazione: Abhidheya.
Quindi Sambahanda è
la conoscenza della relazione,
Abhidheya i mezzi
per acquisire questa conoscenza,
cioè la disciplina dello yoga.
Bisogna fondare la propria vita
su dei valori etici e universali
e su di questi basare poi
le proprie relazioni
in modo da arrivare ad un'armonizzazione
che passa attraverso la meditazione.
perché è il mezzo attraverso il quale
è possibile purificare la mente
da tutte le false identificazioni
da tutti i falsi condizionamenti,
per raggiungere l'obiettivo.
L'obiettivo è Prayojana:
la conoscenza originaria della relazione,
il raggiungimento di quell'ispirazione
profonda, originaria e ontologica
che ci appartiene,
che ci dona creatività,
che ci dona un benessere sostenibile,
che ci dona visione
e capacità di poter sostenere
la vita nel mondo,
di stare nel mondo
ma senza essere del mondo.
Quindi lo stare nel mondo ispirati,
ma senza essere condizionati dal mondo.
Io vi ringrazio
e spero di potervi rivedere presto.